right got my trusty guitar on my back
last few months I've been working on a
special musical collaboration related to
a very important number in nature we
better head off down the road to meet
this collaborator for the very first
time and I'm very excited about it
[Music]
we're at the studio of mr. dear Brown
here who's a fairytale yes with his
trademark eye who's a very talented
musician producer so we're writing a
song a math metal song about five mouths
metals of genre which has very sort of
mathematically based riffs I guess very
very syncopated very technical and after
we filmed a video and pay for a number
file a few months ago they've gotten
touch and was keen to collaborate and to
really take that idea and push it
further and so what we've done is we've
based a song around the the number of I
base the rhythms based the melody if you
can call it that base the lyrics all
around are all around five the number
five first riff have gotten a song
it's nice clean one
before we punch you in the face and
that's derived from riff Phil came up
with and as you can see here quite
conveniently from the different digits
of Phi what we will also want to do as
well as mapping the digits a Phi on to
the melodies onto the riffs and onto the
rhythms is also somehow embed the
geometry of Phi in the song and the way
we're going to do that is we're going to
take the guitar string I'll enter the
guitar string and we're going to pick
out the note which defines or the
position on the string which defines the
golden ratio the note of the golden
ratio as well and so what we're doing is
we have this is a guitar string from
here to here the fundamental definition
of the golden ratios you've got ear v so
you've got a lengthy end you've got a
length B here so a plus B over a is
equal to a over B and that's equal to
Phi what we're going to do now is use
your wonderful golden ratio calipers
wherever they've gone to define where
that note is it's gonna be a note that's
not gonna match up exactly with where
it's there was enough too far off where
we have a fret on the guitar it's just
slightly below the 17th fret and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
overdub on top of that or maybe build it
up we'll see as deer suggested what
we're going to do is then build this up
so we'll go from that just below the
17th fret then we're going to choose
another note which as you can see is
just around about where they the screws
and the pick up are and then we're going
to subdivide that down again each time
building up and each time defining the
music of the goal other than the note of
the golden ratio geometrically ok so
this next riff I thought it'd be quite
cool if we took the number of chugs that
the guitar plays technical term a chug
is when the guitar goes sounds kinda
like it's onomatopoeic and we took the
number of them and put a gap in between
each one and if you count the number of
chugs between each gap you actually get
the number Phi which is quite cool so
take a listen
[Music]
so there was one choke six chugs one
choke eight yep you get the idea so
these are gold nanoparticles two
nanometers two nanometers across in
water vial what I'm we're not going to
really use the nano part of is what we
are going to use is the vial that the
nano particles are in but of course it's
gold its golden ratio so we thought it
was apt well I thought it was out
[Music]
next up we get to a riff that's kind of
like the PI video that you guys did
where Phil Maps the digits of pi onto a
scale we did that with Phi onto the B
flat harmonic minor scale I'm not really
good at musical deck I do by ear
[Music]
can I get his shouting into the mic I
need to get a level look unfortunately
I'll give you some volume so you can do
it
I've done this for a long long time over
20 years so I was in a band while I was
a student while I was a postgraduate as
well I did a level maths
I got a C it was I blame my teacher I'm
more of a musician now I have a youtube
channel called boy in a band you can
search for that and it'll probably be in
the description I'll make sure Brady
puts it there oh oh there we go how
about that oh but yes I make music of
varying styles lots of electronic music
but I'm horrendously into metal as well
just use horrendously twice I hope
that's okay one six one eight oh three
three nine eight eight seven four it's
been a hell of a lot of fun and I'm
really happy with the song I think we've
done some very interesting things we've
gone beyond you know people talk about
math metal but math metal those riffs
sound complicated but are not really
mapped on to mats in this case we've
actually gone beyond that there's only
one other band to the best of my
knowledge that has attempted anything
like this before and that's a band
called after the barrier so Phi is one
plus the square root of five over two so
we decided to be a bit clever and we
have got one in this by the open string
on the guitar representing that and the
other notes being played by the guitar
are the digits of square root 5 and then
over 2 we go into halftime drums partway
through this which is always quite
clever so
[Music]
that's quite clear isn't it yeah you
pleased with oh yeah some people might
not consider a beautiful I think the way
that the mats are embedded throughout
the song yeah has its own bizarre beauty
about it yes
[Music]
and we do a similar thing for that outro
as well the one there is that
top note then we've got the chugs euro
at chugs are doing square root of five
and again half time drums Leibniz was a
very famous mathematician developed
calculus independently of Newton and he
has this wonderful quote which is that
music is the human mind counting when it
doesn't know that it's counting and
that's great there are these fundamental
links between numbers between maths to
music music and it's great to actually
embed those so tightly as we do in doing
this song well hopefully by now you're
all dying to hear the finished song I
know I am I haven't actually got the
final copy from Dave yet we're gonna
upload it here on the numberphile
Channel on Friday if you're watching
this video after Friday I'll have the
link below the video and you'll be able
to find it of course also below the
video in the description I'll have a
link to Dave's channel you really should
check it out he's a super talented guy
and I'll also have some information
under the video about these golden mean
calipers which were sent to us from New
Zealand they're lots of fun and I'm sure
you're all going to have some questions
about them and we'll be using them in
some future videos we've got coming
about the golden ratio on numberphile in
the weeks and months to come
but for now we'll hear the song on
Friday
[Music]
you